ก็
สวัสดีครับดิอ่าใส่ครับน้องเรียมสยามนัก
เรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนอ้าวันนี้กลับมาเจอกัน
นะเขากลับมาเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียม
ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนโปรไทยนะครับอายุฝั่ง
โน้นฝั่งมด
xxx
เรามาตัวกันวันนี้วันอะไรคะพญาก็วันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันนี้ควรเสาร์
วันเสาร์ๆวันนี้วันเสาร์นะครับวันเสาร์ 5
วันเสาร์วันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันเสาร์เมื่อไหร่วันนี้
26 ค่ะอ๋อโอเควันที่ 26
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือนนี้ใช่ไหมเดือนมีนาคมครับ
นา
26 มีนาคมใช่ครับมีหัวข้อสอบอะไรคะปีคศ
ใช่มั้ยข้อ
2005  22
52 รับปีพศ.นะคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
2565 ขับตอนนี้ที่เราคุยกันอยู่กี่โมง
หรอคะพี่อ่าตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วนะพี่ดูเวลา
ก่อนหน้า 9 โมง 9  6  27 นาที
มีลูกสาวสวยด้วย
17 นาทีที่ 5 ใส่ครับ
มี
ตั้งแต่ครั้งที่แล้วนะคะลองแล้วเล่า
เรื่อง
ลืมเล่ามี Spiderman  1  5  Spiderman  1
เราไปแล้วโอเค
Spiderman ภาค 2  5 ภาคและก็เล่าไปแล้ว
เหมือนกันใช่ครับ
แต่วันนี้ล่ะวันนี้ที่
อะไรนะขออันนี้จะเล่าต่อ
เราต่ออีกข้างนึงอ๋อ
อย่าให้กลับทางนี้ก็เป็นภาพที่ 3 ใช่ไหม
ภาคที่ 3 ค่ะอ๋อโอเค
ในภาคที่ 3 นี้นะคะสไปเดอร์แมนอ่ะเขาก็
เงินดูก่อน
มีกันดูแล้วนะจดๆไว้
ในภาคที่ 3 เนี่ย
เพี้ยนพี่จำได้ไหมว่าภาพที่หนึ่งอ้ะอ๋อ
r.e. เตอร์กับแฮร์รี่ที่เขาเป็นเพื่อน
กันชายปีเตอร์เป็นเพื่อนกับแพรี่ใช้ครับ
ใส่แล้วแฮร์รี่ก็
คิดว่าอิอิเตอร์เป็นคนฆ่าพ่อเขาไปกับ
แล้วในภาคภาพนี้นะคะภาคที่ 3 หา
ปีเตอร์เขาก็ไปเจอไปเจอชุด
ควีนอะไรนะคะพี่อาชีพจีนก๊อปลิงค์ Green
ก๊อปลิงค์น่ะหาเป็นชุดของพ่อชุดของข้อ
แฮร์รี่ใช่ไหมครับโอเค
แล้วก็ผิดเอออะไรนะยาสีเขียวๆมันจะเป็น
ยาสีเขียวแล้วเขาก็เอายาสีเขียวน่ะมาฉีด
ตัวเองว่าฉีดเข้าไปจะได้มีพลังเหมือน
Green กริมก็อบลินใช่ไหม
จะได้มีพลังและเตรียมก็คิดนะว่า
ยาสีเขียวอยู่ในบ้านแล้วมันคือยาอะไรก็
ไม่รู้อ่ะ
The  Harry เก่ามาชี้ตัวเองฮ่าๆ
ๆใจเออตีคิดว่าคิดว่าแฮร์รี่รู้รู้
ว่านั่นคือยาอะไรอ่ะไส้ครับก็เลยก็เลยเอา
มากี่นะ
ถ้าเกิดแบบไม่รู้แล้วมาฉีดแล้วตายอ้ะ
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันไม่ได้ไม่รู้ถ้าไม่รู้
ห้ามกินห้ามเอามาฉีดถ้าไม่รู้ว่ายาคือยา
อะไรห้ามห้ามใช้ฟิล์มไม่ได้ฉีดไม่ได้ถ้า
ไม่มี
ตอนนี้มีโคบิตใช่ไหมพี่อติใช่ครับก็ยัง
คิดแบบไม่อยากฉีดวัคซีนเลย
เฮ้ย
แต่ Harry เห็นยาสีเขียวอ่ะเอามาชี้ตัว
เองหมอ
เพราะแฮร์รี่รู้แฮร์รี่รู้ๆ
พี่มาลีรู้
แฮร์รี่ก็มีพลังไงไซน์อัพ
โอเคเราในตอนเนี้ย
ในตอนนี้อาแฮรี่ย์วิทช์แฮนด์นี่ either
ปีเตอร์กับป้าป้า
มีอ้าฟิตป้าเมย์ใช้ครับปีเตอร์อยู่บ้าน
อยู่บ้านเดียวกับป้าเมย์
ถ้ามีได้ครับคุณตำรวจ
ตำรวจเขาก็บอกให้อิเตอร์กับป้าหมี่
ไปคุยคุยคุยกับตำรวจ
บอกว่าเขารู้แล้วว่าใครอ่ะฆ่าลุงเบ็นอ๋อ
อ่าจับได้แล้วก็จับคนที่ฆ่าลุงเบ็นได้
แล้วใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะจับได้แล้ว
ว่าใครที่ค่าหลุมเบนซ์ครับ
แต่ว่าตอนนี้คนที่ฆ่าลุงเบ็นน่ะ
ที่เขาโดนจับไว้ในคุกใช่ไหมคะอันนี้คือ
คุปต์อ๋ออ๋อคนที่ฆ่าโรงเรียนโดนจับติดคุก
แล้วอ้าอยู่ในคุกใช่ไหมครับน่าอยู่ในคุก
เขาชื่อชื่ออะไรนะเดี๋ยวหาก่อนหาชื่ออะไร
ครับชื่อกินมาโก้ขอ
ดูสินหมากโอ้
จะโดนแจกจับโดนจับเค้าจาก 5 อยู่ในคุก
ครับผมมาแล้วไงต่อครับขับอยู่ในกรุ๊ป
หนีออกมาจากคุก 9 นจะหนีออกมาจากคุกนะ
ครับ
เตรียมก็ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่านี้ออกมาจากคุก
ได้ยังไงอ๋ออ้าแต่ว่าไม่อยู่ในคุกแล้วหนี
ออกมาตำรวจก็เลยตามหาใช่ไหมหาวันนี้ไปที่
ไหนอ่ะตามหามาก็ใช่มั้ยโอเค
น้องสาว ago เขาก็ไปที่บ้านนะคะ
ไปที่บ้านไทยครับ
บ้านของฟินมาโกงขอกินมาก้นหนีออกมาจากคุก
แล้วก็กลับไปที่บ้านของเขาอ้าโอเค
เขามาหาลูกสาวค่ะ
อ๋อเขามีลูกสาวเหมือนกัน
มาเขามีลูกสาวด้วยก็เลยหมีกลับมาที่บ้าน
มาหาลูกสาว
ครับใช่ลูกสาวของเขาไม่สบายขอ
ข้าวแต่ว่าตาแก้ปวดก็มานะครับเนี่ยที่
ตำรวจก็ตามมานะครับตำรวจที่ที่อยู่ที่ 6
ใช่ไหมมาตามจับตามจับไปเข้าคุกเหมือนเดิม
จับกินหมากโตถามมาโก้นี้นี่มีนี้ๆนั้นมี
แล้วก็
ที่เสียบปลั๊ก
ของเฮียที่ชาร์จอะไรอ่ะตีเสียบปลั๊ก
คอมพิวเตอร์โอเคเรียบร้อยแล้ว
ที่เราก็มันจะมีบ่
อันนี้เรียกว่าบอก
ปิดมาโก้ก็หนีหม้อนี้มามีมาที่บ่อนี้ใช่
ไหมครับ
แล้วก็
ตกลงไปในบ่อตกลงไม่ได้บ่บ่นี้เป็นบอกอะไร
ครับ
บ่อทรายค่ะอ๋อมีทรายอยู่ในบ่อ S ทำไมมี
ทรายอยู่ในบ่อนี้ครับอ่ะก็
เพราะว่ามีคนอยู่ข้างนอก
ขอคนที่อยู่ข้างนอกบ่
คนที่อยู่ข้างนอกบ่อทรายอ๋อดูบ่อทรายครับ
ผม
ให้แล้วเขาก็กำลังจะแบบกดปุ่มกดแล้วให้
สาย
สายแบบเป็นรายเล็กๆอ๋อกดปุ่ม
นิกายเป็นสายเล็กๆอ๋ออ๋อให้เป็นทรายเม็ด
เล็กๆครับผมอ่านแล้ว
แต่ว่าฟิตมาก็ลงไปขอตกลงไปในบ่อทรายที่
กำลังจะทำให้กลายเป็นทรายเม็ดเล็กๆ
คนตกลงไปในบ่อทรายแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นครับที
นี้เกิดอะไรขึ้นมาก็กลายเป็นทราย on  line
มีทรายเม็ดเล็กๆ
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเขาก็หนีไปหนออ้าแต่ไม่ตายใช่ไหมไม่
ตายตกลงไปในบ่อทรายแล้วกลายเป็นทรายเม็ด
เล็กๆแต่ไม่ตาย
ไม่ตายของเขากลายเป็นทรายแล้วก็กลับมา
เป็นคน
อ๋ออ๋ออ๋อเขาเปลี่ยนเป็นทรายเม็ดเล็กๆได้
เปลี่ยนเป็นทรายได้แล้วก็เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยน
กลับมาเป็นคนได้ด้วย
ใช่ค่ะก็โอเคแล้วตำรวจตำรวจตามมาจับมั้ย
ตำรวจตามมาจับไหม
ตำรวจก็ตามถามตามาจะกลับแต่ว่าตอนนี้จับ
ไม่ได้อ้าวเหรอครับจับไม่ได้ทำไมจับไม่
ได้แล้วครับ
เพราะว่ากินหมากผู้มีพลังอ่ะนะฮะก็กลาย
เป็นทรายได้กลายเป็นทรายเม็ดเล็กๆตำรวจก็
จับไม่ได้อ้ะเพราะเป็นทรายไปแล้วน้อ
โอเคอ้าแล้วก็เลยหนีไปใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะนี้ไปกับเพราะว่าก็มีไปต้นเหมือน
เดิมนะคะพี่อ้าวไม่ได้มีกลับบ้านแล้ว
ไม่ได้หมีกลับบ้านแล้วใช่ไหมครับมีไปปล้น
อ๋อแสดงว่าฟิล์มเธอก็เป็นคนไม่ดีเป็นคน
ไม่ดี
ลูกสาวเขาอ่ะครับลูกสาวของติดมากโอ้ไม่
สบายหมอไม่สบาย
ก็เขาต้องใช้เงินน่ะมากๆอ๋อต้องใช้เงิน
น่ะแต่สิ้นมาก็ไม่มีเงินฟิล์มมาก็เลยไป
ปล้นเงินขอแกหรอกครั้งนี้เขาก็ไปปล้นเงิน
จากรถขนเงินเฮ้ยเฮ้ยกินรถขนเงินไหม 5 สวย
เห็นครับเป็นรถนามิตู้ขนเงินอยู่ด้านหลัง
รถเอ้อใส่เงินมาเคก็เป็นเงิน
เงิน
กินมาก็มา
เอาเงินหมอมาเอาเงินที่รถขนเงินไปอ่า
เรียกว่าปล้นเงินใช่ไหมอ๋อมาปล้อนเงินเค
แล้วในตอนนั้นเองที่
ที่มันมีมันมีอะไรสักอย่างค่ะพี่อติครับ
ก็ต้องมา
เป็นสีดำๆนะ
ตกลงมา
แล้วมันก็แบบเป็นตัวที่ที่แบบเหนียว
เหนียวอ่ะแม่เลี้ยงเหนียวขออ่อนเหนียวสี
ดำๆกับตกลงมาจากไหนครับตกลงมาจากจากตรง
น้องฟ้าใช่ไหมหนาจากบนท้องฟ้าตกลงมาในใน
ในโลกของเราใช่ไหมอ๋อ
ตกลงมาในโลกเรางานตกลงมาที่ไหนครับ
ตกลงมาที่พื้นดินอ๋อโอเคอ่ะพื้นดินถ้าตก
ลงมาบนโลกครับมันคืออะไรครับลูกมันคือ
อะไรที่ตกลงมา
ยังไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าคืออะไรแต่ว่ามันแบบ
ยืดได้อ๋ออ๋อเป็นสีดำๆเดี๋ยวเหนียว
หืมเหนียวแล้วก็เป็นดิบมาเหรออ๋อ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หมอเขารีบว่าปรสิตขอ
เป็นปอนด์ละ 40 ใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะเป็น
ปรสิตตัวนี้มันต้องมา
มันต้องมาจากที่คน
ที่คุณรักคนก็จะ
โกรธหรืออุ่นอ๋อก็จะมาควบคุมควบคุมความ
คิดของคน
น้าให้โอเค
แล้วก็
either ปีเตอร์เขากำลังคิดเรื่องลุงเบ็น
ถูกที่ถูกฆ่าขับ
แล้วตัวปรสิต
ปรสิตสีดำๆก็มาเกาะ either ขอ
หน้ามาก่อปีเตอร์อ้าแล้วก็ควบคุมความคิด
ถ้าเจอด้วยไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะน้องปีเตอร์โหดๆเหอๆ
แล้วก็
ปิดเตอร์ก็ออกไปออกไปสู้
ครับเข้ากับอะไรนะ
กินหมากโอ้ขอบอกว่า
ฟินมากกว่าที่เขากลายเป็นไซส์เม็ดเล็กๆ
ได้ใช่ไหมหา
เรียกอีกอย่างว่า sandman ขอเรียกแปลว่า
sandman อ่ะหรือเรียกว่ามนุษย์ทรายใช่
ไหมครับมันอุสาตามนุษย์ซ้ายก็เลยมาสู้กับ
มาสู้กับปีเตอร์ที่เป็นไอ้แมงมุมด้วยนะ
ทรายกับไอ้แมงมุมมาสู้กันอ่าโอเค
S แต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ปีถ้าเธอปีเตอร์โดน
เอ่อปีเตอร์โดนปรสิตน่ะควบคุมความคิดอยู่
จ๊ะอ๋อเกาะอยู่ที่ตัวปีเตอร์ก็เลยเป็นตัว
ปีเตอร์ก็เลยเป็นสีดำใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะจะ
เป็นสไปเดอร์แมน
Spider  Man สีดำอ๋อเป็นสไปเดอร์แมนตัว
สีดำน่ะทั้งตัวเลยเพราะว่ามีปรสิต Bangkok
อยู่เป็นตัวเขาเอามาควบคุมความคิดคำให้
โกหดโกรธง่ายใช่ไหมครับ
โอเคเราก็ไปสู้กับ sandman หน้าไปสู้กับ R
sandman มนุษย์ทรายโอเค
5 สู้กันเป็นยังไงบ้างครับใครชนะครับ
ปีเตอร์ชนะคะอ๋ออ๋อปีเตอร์ฉันนั้น
เพราะว่า
ติดเอ้อรู้ว่าแฟนแนนโดนก็ไม่ได้อ๋ออ๋อ
เพราะเป็นทรายนะเวลาทรายโดนน้ำแล้วเป็น
ยังไงครับก็
ละลายอ๋ออ๋อก็จะไม่แข็งแรงใช่นะอ่าเป็น
เอ่อเป็นคนไม่ได้เวลาโดนน้ำก็จะเปียกแล้ว
ก็ละลายลงไปละลายๆ
จนน้ำ
แล้วก็ละลาย
either คิดว่าคิดว่า sandman น่ะตายแล้ว
กลับ
ก็เลยอ่ะโอเคชนะแล้วหารได้แล้วอ๋ออ๋อ
เพราะว่าปีเตอร์ใช้น้ำแต่ว่าไม่ตายเหรอ
ครับไม่ตายไม่ตายขอเข้าไป
น้ำน้ำออกไปหมดแล้ว
ก็ไปหมดอ่ะจะแต่งงานก็กลับมาเป็นคนอีก
หน้า
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็ตอนนี้อ่ะปีเตอร์ก็กลายเป็นคนที่
โกรธง่ายๆน้อใช่ครับเพราะว่ายังโดนอ่า
ปรสิตหน้าควบคุมความคิดอยู่ก็เลยโกรธง่าย
เฮ้อขับใช่แล้วที่นี้ปีเตอร์ทำยังไงครับ
ปีเตอร์ก็ไปไปร้านอาหารนะคะกลับร้านอาหาร
ที่ mj ทำงานอยู่ที่ต่ำจริงๆได้ไหม
อ่ะจำได้ครับ mj เป็นเพื่อนเพื่อนผู้หญิง
ของสไปเดอร์แมนโอเคไปได้มันก็เลยไปหา mj
ใช่รัก mj อยู่
mj งานทำงานอยู่ในร้านอาหารกับ
หมอเขาว่าครั้งนี้ปิดเอ้อเนี่ยไปเต้นเล่น
กับผู้หญิงอีกคนนึงไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ไปเต้นกับผู้หญิงมีคนนึงอ๋อมีผู้หญิงคน
อื่นอยู่ที่ร้านอาหารที่ mj ทำงานอยู่
ด้วย 5 ปีเตอร์ก็เลยไปเต้นกับผู้หญิงอีก
คนนึงอ่ะครับแล้วเป็นไงครับแล้ว mj ว่าไง
ครับ mj บอกว่ายังไง
mj เห็น NJ เห็นไหมเห็บ mj ก็เห็นปี
เตอร์เคแล้วก็โกรธได้มั้ยอ๋ออ๋อเลขโกรธ
เราก็แต่ว่าปีเตอร์เนี่ยก็เหมือนผักค่ะ mj
หนอ
กินเจก็ล้มลงขอผัก mj  mj ล้มลงครับ
เธอก็เลยคิดคิดขึ้นมาได้ว่ากูมีกี่คนรัก
NJ นะ
ทำไมทำไมทำแบบไม่ดีกับ ng ใช่รัก mj แต่
ว่าผัก mj ล้มนะไม่ดีครับมิเตอร์รู้มีเธอ
ก็คิดได้ใช่ไหม
คิดว่าเป็นเพราะปรสิตออกขอ
แต่มันเหมือนหลุมฝั่งศพมากเลยฮ่าๆไปที่
โบสถ์อาทิโบสถ์โอเคไปทำอะไรที่โบสถ์
ไปแล้วก็คิดว่าจะเอาปรสิตออกอ๋อ
จะเอากลสิทธิ์อ่ะออก
เราเขาก็
พยายามดึงก็บ่อดูเหงาออกใช่ไหมดึงออกไป
ออกไปแล้วออกไหมออกได้ไหม
ออกค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเออติดเอ้ออยู่ตรงนี้นะหรือ
แล้วมันจะมีราคาง
ระฆังแล้วเขาก็ดึงออกแบบว่ามีคนอยู่ข้าง
ล่างค่ะที่อ๋ออ๋อมีคนอยู่ข้างล่าง
ด้วย
คนอยู่ข้างล่างคนนี้คือเอ็ดดี้
แอ๊ดดี้คอปีเตอร์บินปรสิตอีกแล้วอ่ะกลับ
ปรสิตมันตกลงมาขอลงมา
แล้วก็มาเกาะแอ๊ดดี้มาเกาะแอ๊ดดี้ต่อไม่
เกาะสไปเดอร์แมนแล้วปรสิตก็เกาะแคดดี้คน
อื่นอีกคนนึงเหรออ้าแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อครับ
แล้วแอ๊ดดี้ก็กลายเป็นเวราววขออ๋อไกลเป็น
ตัวสีดำเหมือนอะเหมือนตอนที่ 10 ไป
เดอร์แมนเป็นสีดำกาดตอนนี้ตัวปรสิตไม่ได้
กอดไปได้มาแล้วใส่ให้มันไม่เป็นสีดำนะมา
เกาะที่เอ็ดดี้อีกคนหนึ่งแทนอ๋อใช่หือพี่
ก็จะจ่ายเป็นตัวสีดำๆๆเค
ตัวสีดำๆกับแล้วก็มีฟันน่ะฟันแหลมๆศ.
หน้าเริ่มเริ่มดุไม่ดุร้ายใช่ไหม
ๆหายๆคะ
แล้วก็
ในเรื่องนี้ก็เลยมีตัวร้ายอยู่สองตัวก็
คือแฟนแนนครับเออ
แล้วยังไม่หมดค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ทำได้ไหมแค่
นี่
หือแครีก็เป็นกรีนก็อบลินปิ้งนาฬิกาเพลง
พร้อมบินโห้มีมีตัวร้าย 3 ตัวเลยมีเวร
อ้อมมีแฟน Man แล้วก็มีกินบ๊อบบิ้นโอเค
อ่าสไปเดอร์แมนต้องสู้กับสามคนนี้ต้องสู้
กับสามคนนี้
กระเป๋าว่า
โชคดีมากค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้อาบพี่แฮร์รี่เนี่ย
แฮร์รี่เขารู้รู้จักข้อบ้านจะมีพ่อบ้าน
ครับบ้านที่ทำงานให้แฮร์รี่ที่ทำงานอยู่
ในบ้านแทนหน้าที่คอยช่วยหาเรียกเป็นพ่อ
บ้านกับหูก็เลยมาบอกบอกแฮรี่ว่าเขารู้ว่า
ข้อของแฮร์รี่
ที่นอร์แมนใช่ไหมถ้าใช่ครับ
ตายเพราะว่า
เขาว่าอะไรนะมีดของตัวเองอ๋อ
หน้าพ่อบ้านรู้ว่าพ่อของแครี่ไม่ได้ตาย
เพราะว่าสไปเดอร์แมนค่าสไปเดอร์แมนไม่ได้
ค่าอ๋อ
พ่อบ้านก็เลยมาบอกแครีใช่ไหม
แฮร์รี่ก็เลยอ๋อสไปเดอร์แมนไม่ได้ค่าหรือ
ก็เลยไปช่วยสไปเดอร์แมนต่อ
ไปช่วยสไปเดอร์แมนที่กำลังสู้พี่อยู่กับ
แฟนแนน
แต่เห็นแมนแล้วก็ตัวเวรอ่ะววหรือ
ใส่สู้ก็ตัว Venom เนี่ยมันไม่ชอบเสียงนะ
หนอนล่ะครับ Venom ไม่ชอบเสียงไม่ชอบ
เสียงอะไรครับไม่ต้องเสียงดังไม่ชอบเสียง
เหมือนเสียงรา kang แต่
ขอ
เหอะแล้วก็
สไปเดอร์แมนก็เลยเอาเสาเสามาเสียบเสา
เหล็กนะคะเสียบครับรอบๆ anal
เราก็ทำให้มันมีเสียง
ขอ
ไปน้องก็จะออกไม่ชอบไม่ชอบไปน้อมกลัว
เสียงเราโอเคครับใช่ค่ะแล้วเขาก็เลยดีมี
ตัวแอ๊ดดี้ออกมา
อะดีออกมาครับแล้วจะเอาระเบิด
ระเบิดของแฮร์รี่ค่ะโยนเข้าไปขอ
กลับโรบินต้อมตายต่ออะดีก็วิ่งเข้า
ไปอ้าว
ระเบิดไปพร้อมกับพี่น้องอ๋อๆ
หือ
sandman  sandman ก็ได้คุยคุยกับปีเตอร์
sandman บอกว่า
ปีเตอร์เอ่อลูกสาวลูกสาวของแฟนแนนไม่สบาย
ใช่ครับเลยหาเงินหาเงินไปรับสารสาว
แล้วก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้อยากฆ่าลุงเบ็นอ๋อ
แต่ว่า
มีเพื่อนเพื่อนของเขาวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งมาแล้ว
สินหมาโคตรตกใจปืนของเขาก็เลยลั่นตั้งขอ
โดนลุงเบน
ลุงเย็น
รถเบนซ์ก็เลยตายเขาไม่ได้อยากป้าลุงเบ็น
เขาปืนมันลั่นถึง
หน้าสไปเดอร์แมนก็เลยรู้
เออ
ไม่โกรธครับแล้วก็ sandman  sandman ก็
หายไปหือหายไปก็โอเคจบเรื่องนี้อ๋อ
อุ๊ยเก่าว่าแคร์รี่ตายนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้ขอ
เรื่องนี้ตอนนี้ Harry  Styles ช่วย
สไปเดอร์แมนแล้วตัวเองก็ตายด้วย
ใช่
จบภาคที่สาวภาคพี่ก็จะจบน่ะก็เหลือแฮร์
รี่แฮร์รี่ยังไม่ตายอ้ะโอเคอ่าสายนะคะพี่
เหลือปีเตอร์เอ้อเดี๋ยวพี่ไปเห้อเหลือ M
ใช่ไหมอ่าโอเค sandman ก็ไปอ่ะเคขับ
ว้าวน่าจบแล้วสบายเด้อแมน 3 ใช่ไหมครับ
วันนี้ว้าวเห้อกูตอนนี้เราเตรียมเล่าไป
นานไหมเออต่อกินคานนิดหน่อยครับเกินเวลา
มานิดหน่อยไม่เป็นไรครับอ่ะนะต้องถามนัก
เรียนอะนักเรียนฟังฟังน้องเรียมเล่า Learn
ไหมสนุกไหมครับฮ่าฟังเข้าใจไหมนะฮ่าๆฟัง
เข้าใจไหมชอบชอบตรงไหนไม่ชอบไม่ชอบลงไหน
บอกคีย์บอกได้ในคอมเม้นนะครับโอเคแล้ว
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าเรากลับมาเจอกับ
พี่กับน้องเรียนปีใหม่ในช่องคอมเปลี่ยน
Store ไทยจันทร์เล่าจะเล่าเรื่องอะไรนะ
คอยติดตามกันนะครับเดี๋ยววันนี้พี่กับ
น้องเรียนต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนอ่าบ๊ายบายน้องเรียม
อ่าอ่ะ